hi there steve here i'm in london
visiting with my son and his family
we're tonight is christmas eve we're
handing out presents
uh as is our custom
uh
back of course from morocco uh but i
wanted to show you two videos of me uh
trying to engage in arabic with people
in morocco
people who spoke uh standard arabic so i
was able to have a conversation at least
they were able to speak to me in
standard arabic i struggled to speak to
them i did understand what they were
saying
but i want to show you these because i
see right away when i looked at the
videos that there are quite a few
mistakes mostly having to do with
gender i think
i think i speak to
the one lady in the restaurant and i say
she's she is my mu alam which should be
mualimah mualimah female and i think i
said
we will speak or i will speak should be
so again it's a different uh person in
the verb
but i don't mind making mistakes
and
i think it's important like grammar and
grammar rules to my mind are there as
reference we go there as often as we
want as often as we need to we look up
different things we're reminded of
different things
i still focus primarily on comprehension
once we understand well then it becomes
easier to speak the grammar rules have
more meaning we're able to stay in a
conversation because we understand what
other people are saying
it was fun for me to speak to those two
people in standard arabic because it was
real and this is the other thing it's so
important to have meaningful
conversations
that's why the shopkeepers in morocco do
so well because their engagement in
these languages
are meaningful because they're trying to
sell something to the visitors and so
whereas a a discussion in the classroom
very often is not very meaningful so uh
i you can listen to these you can see my
mistakes if you speak arabic but i'm not
concerned and i'm continuing on my
journey and i will also be doing farsi
again with the goal of understanding
first and then eventually improving my
speaking skills
and i wish everyone a merry christmas
and a happy new year and a happy holiday
season
bye for now and listen to those two
videos if you are interested okay so we
are in france
so i'll just introduce briefly
this is the world we live in we live in
a connected world i have my youtube
channel yes and one of the people who
watches my youtube channel is in this
small town in morocco not so small
perhaps
and through youtube we connected yes and
mohammed kindly said if you come to
morocco please come and visit me in my
town so i said fine yes
and we've had a lovely cup of coffee
thank you for your kind of coffee
and uh
and what i want to say is that i came to
morocco it's an arabic speaking country
and of course i've been listening to a
lot of arabic and reading arabic and
wanted an opportunity to speak but it's
very difficult because they speak a
different life what i'm going to
demonstrate now is just how difficult it
is to learn a language because some
people think it's easy that you learn it
in a few months yes and i've spent eight
or nine months listening to arabic and
as you'll soon see i have a lot of
difficulty speaking but we're going to
try yes i'm sorry we can try
yes uh you are welcome first
i am mohammed from morocco
like you say i can't
i can't learn a language in a few months
right it takes a time
you should
three or four years yes
it's this the list yes you should
uh
and
you should listening a lot yes and
reading yes
and after that
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
how would you say
right
how do you say yes
taxi drivers
yes
uh
uh
[Music]
so maybe we you should enjoy and enjoy
the
so we maybe we end on that note and so
as you saw i struggled with my arabic
but it doesn't matter i'm in no hurry i
enjoy it the arab language is not going
away no no and i tend to be around for a
while so
okay
okay
i work for my parents
okay
and what's the name of the town here
what's a town here yes it's azeroth
yes and my restaurant his name is
restaurant el hanna
you speak arabic and me i speak english
[Music]
thanks a lot thanks a lot
[Music]
if you
can
say we have uh four or five berber here
in morocco okay they speak to the camera
so we have here in morocco four or five
berber and it's different between a
person and to another one however
because he has to get back to work the
most important thing is the food here is
delicious thanks a lot raj is a
wonderful host okay it made them feel at
home okay and then waiting for your uh
your notes yes okay
google maps okay okay
go to google maps yes and you give us
your um
okay
[Music]
you